[Music]
you know well killing it
Alicia vikander he is the star of Tomb
Raider you know she works hard to get
Laura Croft cut but she told me the
struggle was definitely real when it
came to what she ate all right so this
is truth-telling time what was tougher
the workouts or the diet that had to go
with the workout oh my god I must say
the diet yeah for sure
I actually enjoyed the workout quite a
lot during the filming add three eggs
and some fruit after workout in the
morning then at 10:00 I had like two
filets of fish a bowl of rice and
vegetables and then similarity one at
4:00 at 7:00 sound like for huge meals
that's not real life I'm gonna I'm back
on you know I'm drinking my wine I'm
eating my food when you rapped and you
said okay I can eat again what was the
first thing that you went for that
veggie list actually so each Sunday
you have cheeping and I would say that
you know it was pizza or pasta it was
like I woke up on Sundays and I looked
round it's pizza day
Alyssia put on 12 pounds of muscle and
did most of her own stunts but she got
the most competitive with her husband
Michael Fassbender at the peak of your
performance you or Michael which one of
you guys could do the most pull-ups yeah
did you watch the Angelina's movies
before I yes I saw the films when they
came out Angelina Jolie has made her
into the icon which is the fate of
humanity is now in your hands
one big perk of being the star of Tomb
Raider Alyssia got to meet Prince
William and Kate for a black-tie dinner
last month the topic of conversation the
crown and Game of Thrones
I had the Swedish Prime Minister on my
left and William on the right I just
remember from Titanic to kind of eat
from from out and work yourself in with
the cutlery and
I loved it she got her etiquette from
Titanic that amazing okay so we know
Alyssia got in Tomb Raider shape with
the help from her trainer Magnus well
Magnus Nick Magnus's next big move he is
training gal gadot to the next Wonder
Woman
[Music]
you